normally Anwar Bakery brings her mother
to a renal dialysis center twice a week
but since the start of fighting getting
access to a hospital with the needed
facilities has been difficult
since the start of the war the health
facility reduces Dialysis in closed we
went to another hospital and started
there but they were only able to do the
dialysis for two hours
we tried several others but cartoon MILF
generally has no power running water
this is my mother's first Dialysis in
two weeks
most of the patients in the dialysis
World here in elno hospital in under Man
City have traveled to get here the
fightings led to most of the 29
hospitals in Khartoum unable to function
Healthcare facilities have been under
pressure since the start of the conflict
some have had to turn away patients
because they don't have the space or
medicine to treat them others have
closed their doors out of fear of being
caught up in the fighting or because of
damages to their buildings
this hospital is one of the few
remaining providing renal treatments to
patients but the staff say they may not
be able to do so for long
patients who come in need dialysis three
times a week can only get one session
and even the dialysis is changing here
due to a shortage in its needs we don't
have enough dialyzers or artificial
kidneys today is the last day for us to
treat kidney patients we don't even have
tubes and gloves there's nothing left
medical staff are in short supply
volunteers help run the hospital's
operations
I'm here because of my sense of
responsibility and nationalism this is
my country and this is the least I can
offer the people who come here are our
friends Brothers neighbors and even if
we don't know them we're all the same
blood so we all need to stand together
a ceasefire signed between the warring
parties is meant to open humanitarian
corridors for those in need of medical
assistance but the fighting continues
threatening to make a dire situation
even worse
Heber Morgan Al Jazeera umdurman